well,
the former rangers player in ibrox
had a new hearing this
morning how are you greetings from cristian
cásseres with super informative from
kirchner español then he faces
charges of driving while intoxicated as well as
driving recklessly in an
accident where he is 80 23  years old lost
her life she passed away when
rocks rear-ended her vehicle in
springdale in early november
there were some failures in the
broadcast line services that caused some
headaches for their users this
impacted ticketmaster which stopped
sales for the  tickets to attend the
atheist concert here in las vegas
according to the company the ticket purchase service will
return to normal
today remember to check your
email if you are on the
waiting list for more details
and everything indicates that las vegas'  could be
chosen for a new franchise of the
ml is the commissioner don garber said that
las vegas' is as the first option  on
the list in terms of expanding the league and
thus confirming that it would be the 30th team,
however there are still details about the
stadium for the new team and we close
with the forecast we will have a
cloudy day today with
temperatures reaching 65 degrees
According to our radar, rain is anticipated
for Thursday and I observed how the
temperatures drop in the next few days,
the minimums being in the 30s. Remember that
we are two weeks away from the official start
of winter. I am Cristian Cáceres with your
iris nao informative clock in Spanish.
Good morning.